i'm charles payne i'm kat timf i'm
stuart varney and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday june 1st 2022 i'm jessica
rosenthal it's been one week since the
horror at an elementary school in texas
but the attention is now on washington
d.c where lawmakers have begun
discussing a change to gun laws again
we're not talking about one solution
that's going to
you know change the world but
several of these things i think put
together an impact significantly on the
problem
i'm dave anthony
while republicans blame president
biden's policies for inflation some
myths the former president i'm
heartbroken that he's not still in the
white house i certainly voted for him i
wanted him to win i think his uh second
term policies would have been remarkable
and remarkably in contrast to 5 a gallon
gasoline and kellyanne conway thinks the
path is clear for a rematch
and i'm will kane and i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
after the mass shooting at robb
elementary school in yuvaldi texas the
demand by some for action on guns
increased much like it does after most
mass shootings though this time like in
sandy hook the majority of the victims
were children and so the calls were in
some cases louder an activist confronted
texas republican senator ted cruz
outside of a restaurant after he spoke
at the nra convention telling him the
deaths of 19 children are on his hands
as president biden left a mass honoring
those killed during his trip to uvalde
demonstrators shouted at him do
something he said we will the president
has done everything that he can
from from from the federal government we
are looking at other executive actions
that we can
possibly do but tuesday white house
spokeswoman corrine jean-pierre said on
this he can't do it alone senate
minority leader mitch mcconnell
confirmed that he encouraged texas
republican senator john cornyn to work
with democrats on gun related
legislation and so it's begun i will do
as i've always done and that is try to
lean forward and meet my colleagues
across the aisle halfway particularly on
matters
involving
the seriousness of gravity that this
does their goal is to find 10 senate
republicans who can agree on something
connecticut democratic senator chris
murphy told abc's this week on sunday
there are more republicans interested in
talking about finding a path forward
this time than i have ever seen since
sandy hook and well in the end i may end
up being heartbroken i am at the table
in a more significant way right now with
republicans and democrats than
ever before he said while they may not
be on board with a ban on certain
weapons there may be something they can
come together on cornyn told reporters
he sees room for some agreement but
murphy said he won't let republicans
drag this out either the votes are there
or they're not the obvious question
isn't just what can lawmakers agree on
but will what they agree on work to stop
mass shootings well i think universal
background checks is sort of a
no-brainer i think 90 percent of the
polls show that the american public is
for it ria kelly is the former police
commissioner of new york city and the
ceo of guardian group i would start with
that because i think it's relatively
speaking low-hanging fruit i also think
that raising the age to 21 for
people
buying any
guns quite frankly
i think would also be
very much supported by the public
i
like the red flag laws it's not a
federal
law i don't think it can become one but
i i think you need a lot more
advertising and i think that police
are not sufficiently informed on the red
flag laws uh i think it can be
uh a significant help
but they're just not
just not known about correctly
can you talk to me a little bit about
background checks because one of the
arguments we hear is fine you can have
universal background checks but many of
these shooters
would pass such a background check no
true i mean this is not a panacea
there's no
you know there's nothing that's going to
solve
all of the the problems
but i think the background check system
itself
has to be uh examined
for instance it's very much dependent on
what states forward to the federal
government
and some states are
faithful at reporting information
others are not and in general you need
an adjudication by a judge
that someone
has significant mental issues
before they'll go into that database i
think somehow that's got to be
that's got to be
adjusted because it's difficult
to get someone before a court and have a
judge make
a determination
now that's an area that has to be
improved
and to require states to be much more
faithful
in reporting their information
you said that um there's no panacea here
right
i don't know if one can stop all mass
shootings right as long as there are
guns uh there may be attacks on on soft
targets but
is there something specific to schools
that can and should be done that that
isn't being done
look let's face it there's a lot of
money out there
covered money
localities have the federal government
certainly has it i think a
some sort of protocol requiring
school security offices
certainly based on a location
would be something to think about uh
quite seriously you know some of these
schools are in very rural areas and it's
difficult for
the police to to get there so i i would
say at the very least
examine those schools that are
uh that are not easily accessible
and fund uh
security personnel whether they be
police officers or security officers
it's a sort of no-brainer these days
what about hardening of schools this
talk of you know this debate around you
know you don't want a school to look
like a fortress you don't you know i
have two little children
i don't want to feel like i'm pulling up
to some sort of jail type facility when
i take them to school but at the same
time i suppose i would rather that than
um
than anything bad happening to them
where are where should we be in your
mind on this debate about how
i guess fortified or or or fenced off
schools should be
a fortified school you know it's word
you're using does not have to look like
a fortified scroll we can things that
you can do you can
harden the glass you can make certain
that the doors
are you know have panic bars on them and
if the doors are
open that an alarm goes off that some
personnel check that those doors uh
immediately i mean i think you can
harden the target without it looking
like a fortress a lot of these things
are just you know common sense if you
think about it we want to be able to
control
the entrance
and you want to be able to you know
screen who's coming into the school
but also you want to make certain that
there's unfortunately
just happened in texas that doors are
not left open
without an alarm going off and obviously
that didn't happen near
you mentioned the age limit 21 there are
some states who've tried to increase the
age limit to 21. i know you can't sell a
handgun if you're a federally licensed
dealer you can't sell a handgun to
somebody under the age of 21. but
after a certain number of mass shootings
some states did look to increase the age
limit to 21 on long guns but we have a
federal appeals court ruling out of
california
that said that was unconstitutional they
upheld the notion of of one needing to
get a hunting license first for certain
long guns but
the general idea of restricting it to 21
was struck down
in the dissent one of the judges
dissented and he said that you can pass
laws like age restrictions to address
certain demographics like if you know
young men are more prone to
violence than another group you you
could pass a law impacting that
demographic is that something that when
you talk about an age limit you agree
with
yes i do
i think unfortunately
we have the historical data to show that
uh
young people being 18 years of age
have
purchased weapons in these mass
shootings
with some irregularity and i think that
the
it's again i know there's a case in
california but i don't know if that case
is going to be appealed or what but i
think it's something that
you know you said congress uh
or maybe the state legislature can
revisit and work around the court
decision or as i say appeal appealing a
decision but i think there's there's
merit in it again we're not talking
about one solution that's going to uh
you know change the world but uh several
of these things i think
put together an impact significantly on
the problem
since the shooting in uvalde i've heard
some bring up the fact that at times
cops may feel outgunned you know
generally when criminals have certain
weapons and i'm old enough to remember
hearing that argument during the assault
weapons ban debate in la at the time we
had the north hollywood shootout i've
since read
mixed reviews of how well the ban worked
that while gun violence didn't
precipitously drop during that time it
did increase after the ban expired
is that something you think should make
a comeback
well i i i don't see it practically
being implemented
you know we have millions of them out
there now that's just the
reality
so i i and again i don't think we're
as a government in the confiscation
business
so
the enforcement of
an assault weapons ban
i think it would be particularly
difficult yeah you could
perhaps stop the sale but you're still
going to have a a large universe of
assault weapons that are out there
you know i don't see any need for a
assault weapon to uh
you know to shoot an animal or a hunt
but we found you know in the 90s that it
was very difficult to define
an assault weapon and of course the
manufacturers work right around it uh
you know again i i if it could be
enforced
you know in some realistic way i'd be
for it
finally sir um i know this might not be
totally in your wheelhouse but we keep
talking about mental health in relation
to these shootings um if you have
someone showing signs of having mental
health issues maybe it's not full-blown
you know psychosis or schizophrenia you
know maybe it's something smaller
i'm just wondering your thoughts about
that we do hear stories about shootings
that have been stopped you know about
plans to attack high schools that were
thwarted it does happen it just doesn't
happen
i guess often enough but what do we do
with this issue with this mental health
issue in your mind
it's a real problem because as i said
the regulations require that someone be
adjudicated by a judge as having a
significant mental issue all we know
that certainly it didn't happen with
this
with his last shooter a judge wasn't
involved in the buffalo
shooter so
i i think the red flag laws are good
as i said but the mental health issue is
a perplexing one
because the information uh
you know you don't want to label
somebody as having a significant mental
issue if in fact all you have is sort of
the supposition or
you know not not clear evidence that
this person has has the problem and
getting there is is a real
hurdle you know people will say oh yeah
we always knew about him he had a you
know a problem but
he or she was not adjudicated
by a judge as having a problem and you
know we
we don't want to take people's property
for
just a uh sort of a hunch
you know you need to have some sort of
uh due process
in in taking uh
taking guns from uh from people
so it's a problem that is not easily
solved and again
one of the issues is even
when there is an adjudication that
information has not been
consistently
reported to the federal government
there's a
wide variety as far as the
reporting
mechanisms and requirements of the
states
so some do it some don't and some do it
better than others
former commissioner kelly thank you so
much for your time and your insight we
appreciate it
thank you
[Music]
this is will kane with your fox news
commentary coming up
we're in a new month
but for most of may gas prices rose
daily hitting record high after record
high this president and our entire team
understands that when the price goes up
at the pump typical families feel it
brian diese is director of the white
house national economic council and he
blames russian president vladimir
putin's ukraine invasion telling fox the
price of diesel and gas at the pump are
up more than 1.50 since putin started
amassing troops at the border now
president biden met yesterday with
federal reserve chairman jerome powell
who's been raising interest rates to
lower prices now the president says he
won't interfere with the fed but
inflation must come down in order to
transition from historic recovery
to a steady growth that works for
american families he detailed his own
plan to do that in the wall street
journal republican arkansas governor asa
hutchinson read that and tells fox
there's a lot of finger pointing
there is a lack of recognition of the
challenge of his restrictions on our
energy supply as being part of the
problem and republicans also blame too
much biden federal coveted spending last
year we are a house divided across the
country the electorate seems very split
washington is very split kellyanne
conway was donald trump's 2016 campaign
manager then counselor to the president
after he won
she just wrote a book here's the deal a
memoir
you know democrats control everything
but it's a 50-50 senate joe biden you
know didn't really get elected with a
mandate to speak of
and that shows you have a divided
democratic party except on issues like
guns and abortion and they all have one
point of view on each of those even
though the country has many points of
views on those
and uh
look i think in the case of president
trump the reason people who couldn't
wait to get rid of him can't quite quit
him and so talk about him is because he
was an active president you know the
white house i worked in
no one ever had to ask who's in charge
who's the president
you wrote in the book that he's always
listening and he may not be looking like
it or you may not be writing something
down but you said he's always always
listening yes and how do i know donald
trump is always listening well
first of all he repeats verbatim what
you told him
later that afternoon that week that
month or several years later and it's
pretty remarkable i do write in the book
that donald trump rarely forgets
anyone or anything even if you wish he
would
um and he just got a remarkable memory
this is legendary in new york legendary
among his friends and colleagues and i
think some of his competitors in real
estate and tv and these other
major industries in which he has
excelled
you know one of the dumbest things said
about president trump is that he loves
yes men and yes women it's actually not
true dave because he aborts
obsequiousness he doesn't want people
around him who just say yes sir no sir
yes sir you're right sir sir he actually
wants to know what's new
what what you're thinking
how you're feeling what's going on what
he needs to know and i always look at my
job as not telling him what he wanted to
hear but what he needed to know
and he's just a great broad shoulder
boss who can who can hear that take that
assimilate that and act on that you know
during his presidency though there were
all these stories that he would just
rage in the oval office he'd watch cable
tv and shout out to television and uh
you know he had his daughter there as an
advisor he had jared kushner he had all
these people around him and and uh he
was you know he thought he was smarter
than the generals smarter than everybody
else
when you would see and hear that what
did it make you think it made me think
that the people saying that and writing
that and gossiping that two things about
them number one
they've never worked in any white house
little in this white house at this level
so they have no idea it's just
conclusions in search of evidence gossip
people employees staffers in the white
house who had to slink away in shame or
who
were fired this is always their version
of events you should we should all
applaud the fact that president trump
presided over what i refer to as the
democratization of information
so whether you like the facebook post or
the tweet or bringing the press into the
oval office or running into the press
briefing room himself and speaking
directly to the public any way you slice
it through any form you cite
that was a president a
commander-in-chief
transparently
and
instantly free of charge to the country
providing a presidential communication
so if it's a tweet everybody gets to see
at the same time whether you no matter
what your social economic status
no matter your where you live what your
political affiliation is everyone
received presidential communication
instantly and free of charge it's pretty
remarkable and now you've gone all the
way the other way yeah now obviously he
can't tweet anymore and he was uh kicked
off facebook all after what happened on
on january 6th and and there were a lot
of people who were happy he can't tweet
anymore because there were people who
put up these counters of all the lies
and all the tweets that he did and was
there there was always the critics were
saying he's lying thousands of times the
tweets how difficult were they at times
to deal with when you were working for
him well i would joke with the president
that he needs to tweet like we need to
eat it's just about better choices my
favorite tweets were the ones where he
was informing the public about something
his president
was doing or a head of state he was
meeting with or a piece of legislation
that he was getting behind and wants to
make sure that people frankly get behind
their tell their own congressman to get
behind it so i think when the president
was in his inform the public
role but also you know people say oh he
was personally insulting this one excuse
me he always says he's a counterpuncher
and there's something to that
and i'm heartbroken that he's not still
in the white house i certainly voted for
him i wanted him to win
i think his uh second term policies
would have been remarkable and
remarkably in contrast to 5 gallon
gasoline infants who can't find baby
formula who hooked up the tubes
in hospitals instead of just eating
basic nutrition
as provided through infant formula the
border would be more secure putin would
not be in ukraine how do i know that
because donald trump was president and
putin was not in ukraine iran as a
nuclear-capable threat would not be
salivating as it stares at israel across
the way
energy independence would be flourishing
would still be happening so the list
goes on and on you know
you talked about um you know in 2020 and
you wish you'd won
that's still
a big point of contention because he
still insists that he was the winner
that it was stolen from him and of
course she wrote in the book that that
you were one of the people in his inner
circle that told him he lost
but then he bristled at that and he put
something out recently that she never
told me that and if she had i wouldn't
have dealt with her uh any longer and
and she would have been wrong
have have you spoken to him at all since
the book came out have you had any
contact because clearly you did have
contact with him after you left the
white house still
i i have talked to him since the book
came out the president had every right
to
go and find the theft the fraud evidence
of malfeasance and shenanigans of which
there was plenty
sadly joe biden is the president but i
don't think election was totally fair
because i think we'll never really know
okay and i write about that in my book
and i say you know they say on the
person it was it was in reference to him
coming up short before that december
14th deadline of the electors certifying
the election now other people had other
views oh let's blow past december 14th
and go look at january 6th when congress
certifies the election and see if we can
stop it there so everybody saw how that
played out everybody saw the president's
lawyers and strategists and i think a
bunch of supplicants and showmen also
coming before the vessel desk and
promising things that they could not
deliver
and it frankly wasn't fair to him um do
you think they got bad advice to keep
going and then to go out there and rally
on january 6th then obviously there's
the fallout that's still going on with
hearings and everything well listen he
did not go to the capitol he did not
there's no evidence that i've seen that
i've read that he knew what was planned
at the capitol but you know your point
lots of people have been testifying to
the january 6 commission we don't know
where all that is headed
um i think that it's gone on long enough
it's a taxpayer-funded commission
where's where's the joe biden the
democrats and the few never trumpers
school safety commission
we had one in the trump white house
after parkland i don't see you know this
this
this democratic party and the never
trumpers yeah i repeat myself
they are so hellbent on
stopping him on destroying him it's very
corrosive to our body politic
and look there are plenty of laws on the
books that could be enforced against
criminal or civil activity that was
committed on january 6 but making a
mistake david
there were about why i read somewhere
about 662 or so people in the capital
that day that went inside that breached
the capital there were 74 million trump
voters and people want to complete the
two all the trump voters are in the
capital but all the trump murders hurt
the police officers and
we're being disrespectful and swinging
flag poles and gassing each other no
that's a small relatively small number
of people and the 74 million shot voters
i believe are very important historic
number for a sitting president highest
number of votes any sitting president
ever received in the history united
states of america
and who speaks for them where will they
go they actually want back the great
economy the energy independence the i
think more affordability more security
and they want all that back and if if
president trump wants to be president
again i think the path is pretty clear
he's got to run against joe biden and
have a rematch so you you think he's
going to run and do you want him to run
i know he would like to run because he
he knows he's got unfinished business
and did a great job the first time by
and large and so i know that he's
itching to do that everybody wants him
to be the king maker but he was the king
and there's more you can do when you are
than just being the king maker and sort
of living with the quality of the
campaigns and quality of candidates that
you're endorsing where you can have very
little control over that beyond your own
endorsement so he would like to i
wouldn't be surprised if he does well
you opened the book you opened the book
with the story about how you became his
campaign manager and you told him in
august to 2016 that he can win but he's
not winning that he was losing do you
think that he might want you to do it
again in 2024 and would you well that's
up to him i really first and foremost
what are the ages and stages of my
children what's my best and highest use
how can i help the effort to get rid of
joe biden and kamala harris pronto um
and you know as soon as available and
then of course moving forward with my
best and highest use in any new
republican administration or white house
now you've had a career of
studying people polls
reading the tea leaves of where we are
what do you think 2022 and what where
are we headed in your view i think 2022
in some ways is going to be a course
correction
against the biden excesses and
incompetence 2022 is also in a very
unusual way going to be a continuation
of the
house successes in 2020 so not a single
incumbent republican lost his or her
house seat in 2020 and in fact of the 15
seats that went from blue to red they
were taken by
veterans women or minorities or
two or three of the above that's pretty
remarkable
and with these razor thin margins in the
house and senate senate is tied
fifty-fifty copley harris is a
tie-breaking vote and in the house where
the democrats have the narrowest margin
since a majority margin since
world war two
it's not going to take much to switch
that around to really revolutionize it
and turn it around so i think it could
be a monster year but only if the
republicans have messages you can't
replace great messages with messengers
people want to hear the substance they
want to know how you're going to solve
the problems but you're going to do this
differently how you're going to restore
a lot of this peace and prosperity that
we all became accustomed to enjoying
including a lot of non-trump voters
the book is here's the deal a memoir
from kellyanne conway who was former
counselor to the president in the last
administration congratulations on the
book thanks very much for joining us
thank you for having me today david all
the best
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to everyone talks to
liz fox business's liz clayman talks
with entrepreneurs and executives about
inspiring and motivational stories
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
will kane
what's on your mind
in the wake
of the horrible tragedy
in uvalde texas the nation is going to
look for the handrail of sanity the
nation is going to look
for solutions
for many
that is going to mean focusing
on the tool that's going to mean
focusing on the gun
but for me
i think we have to begin to look at the
root
and the cause
of what it is that is causing a
seemingly
mind-blowing increase in young men
randomly walking into a school and
taking
the lives of the most vulnerable
kids
something has broken in our society
something
seems to be broken beyond repair
we have watched over
years and decades now the disintegration
of all the ties that bind us
as a people the family unit has been
de-emphasized we're seeing more and more
children grow up in
fatherless homes
more and more young people are at even
younger and younger ages
being put on pharmaceutical drugs
to mask
the difficulties of becoming an adult
we plug in to a phone bury our nose in
social media isolate from our community
lose friends and lose family play
violent video games which work in effect
as simulators nascar drivers driving
simulators fighter pilots fly in
simulators we have a
generation of young boys who are now
in first person shooter simulators
but something has rotten at the core of
our culture
and most acutely in the hearts and minds
of young men
we have to do something about a culture
that has now de-emphasized masculinity
deprived ourselves of any
male role models
in fact water down the idea of what it
is to even be a male we can't even
biologically define anymore what it is
to be a male and we look up with
surprise when we see people who are
totally callous disconnected
disenfranchised
and rotten at the core who decide the
only way to find purpose and meaning in
life the only way to find their way
their identity is to do the most heinous
act imaginable to resort to evil we must
do something to save our young men we
must do something to save our culture we
must refine
purpose and meaning we need to look back
to the family we need to look back to
community and we must look back to
spirituality if not we're just focused
on the tools we're just focused on the
surface
we're not focused on the core
or the root
of the problem
hey for more of this go check out the
will kane podcast i'll dive deep on the
issues in our society our politics and
our culture and i'll have some fun when
it comes to the world of sports
including breaking down the truth and
fiction this week behind top gun
maverick on the will kane podcast
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcast network
download listen and be inspired with
lauren green's lighthouse faith fox news
religion correspondent lauren green uses
her wealth of stories to take the
listener on a unique journey of
spiritual discovery subscribe and listen
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes